Hey Thoughty2 here.
Yellowstone park experiences between 1,000
to 3,000 earthquakes every year.
Welcome to RIF
There is a basketball court on the top floor
of the U.S. Supreme Court Building.
It is known as "the highest court in the land."
During the first two years of a baby's life,
new parents will miss six months of sleep
on average.
A fish can drown in water.
Just like humans, fish need oxygen to survive,
so if there isn't enough oxygen in the water,
they will suffocate.
Humans can survive longer without food than
they can without sleep.
In 2010 there there were more farm animals
living in the U.S. than there were humans
on earth.
Tea is the most widely consumed beverage in
the world, after water.
The word decimate doesn't mean to completely
destroy, it actually means to remove 1/10th
of something.
It comes from the Latin "Decimare", which
was the practice of killing every 10th Roman
soldier if they tried to mutiny.
Research shows that men know they're falling
in love after just three dates, but on average
women don't fall in love until date number
14.
And finally, there is a condition called Koro
or "penis panic" it's a type of mass hysteria
in which men believe their penises are vanishing.